en esta ocasión vamos a multiplicar un
dígito por cuatro dígitos entonces
digamos 9 por qué te parece 8.085 ajá
entonces 9 por 8 1.085 parece que va a
estar divertido esto y como siempre
pongo la anotación estándar 8.085 arriba
y el 9 en lugar de las unidades abajo
entonces hacemos esta multiplicación el
9 va a multiplicar a cada uno de los
dígitos en 8 1.085 empezamos por el 5
entonces 9 por 5 es igual a 45 el 5 lo
pongo en el lugar de las unidades y
llevamos 4 en el lugar de las decenas
ahora seguimos con el con el siguiente
dígito que es el 8 hacemos
9 por 8 es igual a 72 pero llevamos 4
entonces le sumamos esos 4 72 más 4 eso
es igual a 76 el 6 lo voy a poner aquí
en el lugar de las decenas aquí abajo y
llevamos 7 perfecto ahora recuerda el 9
multiplica cada uno de los dígitos en 8
1.085 entonces
cuál sigue sigue el 0 cierto entonces
multiplicamos 9 por 0 + 7 no olvides ese
7 lleva 7 entonces los sumas a la
multiplicación 9 por 0 es igual a 0 7 es
igual a 7 pongo el 7 aquí y ya casi
terminamos solamente falta multiplicar 9
por 8 entonces vamos a hacer eso 9 por 8
eso es igual a 72 entonces 72
simplemente lo pongo aquí abajo porque
ya no hay más dígitos entonces pongo 72
aquí y tenemos que 8 mil 85 por 9 es
igual a 72 mil 765 hagamos otro ejemplo
hagamos otro porque quiero que te quede
claro el procedimiento de hacer la
multiplicación y también sepas por qué
funciona entonces qué te parece si
hacemos otro ejemplo de un dígito por 4
dígitos 7 por 5 mil 396 entonces vamos a
bueno
intenta lo intenta lo pone pausa el
vídeo y intenta ser la multiplicación
seguro te sale entonces voy a hacerlo en
la forma que me gusta hacerlo con esta
anotación 5.396 por 7 y el 7 va a
multiplicar a cada uno de los dígitos en
5 mil 396 7 por 6 sabemos que es 42
entonces pongo el 2 en las unidades y el
4 llevamos 4 ahora 7 por 9 es igual a 63
más 4 eso es igual a 67 pongo el 7 aquí
abajo en el lugar de las decenas y
llevamos 6 en el lugar de las centenas
en este caso
ahí está 67 ahora vamos con el siguiente
dígito 6 por 3 eso es igual a 21 más 6
que llevamos eso es igual a 27 27
entonces lo que sigue es poner el 7 aquí
abajo en el lugar de las centenas y
llevamos 2 ahora vamos con 7 por 5
finalmente 7 por 5 eso es igual a 35 más
dos
a 37 perfecto entonces tenemos que cinco
mil 396 por siete es igual a 37 mil 772